sandra albers pitched a few times over
his career throughout his career with
the minnesota twins we're gonna see him
throw a lot of strikes tonight 91
innings down in aaa
only nine walks pretty conservative lead
at first
and a bouncer left side simmons flips to
second that wraps up the first inning
and a hitless scoreless first for andrew
albert
left-hander eric lauer parker yeah
making start number 14. he's got a 354
earned run average you know the brewers
have won his last three starts
one hop smash
telez has it
and rush niner will beat the flip to the
bag
[Applause]
juggled it it was hit hard but rest
nighter busted out of the box and
reached first base you can see grab
snyder smelling a hit all the way right
there there's donaldson the designated
hitter
driven to left a bullet
a home run
[Applause]
number 20 for donaldson
and the twins strike first
josh donaldson staying hot had a couple
bumpers in boston jumped on a first
pitch from eric lauer right there nice
swing you see it right here a little bit
of a cut action
caught just too much of the plate on the
inside corner i think he was actually
trying to throw that away
josh donaldson was all over it
twitch did not have a good road trip
donaldson did
five home runs 23 knocked in and the 1-0
pitch ground ball left side picked by
ostedio slides to his feet throws him
out
costa deal got a good bounce in his step
here early tonight went down to his left
to make that play on kane one out ceno
near the line weekly hit right side
polanco charges in from right picks it
and throws him out
max kepler leading things off for the
twins here
and he sends that one into left center
field kane will run it down
nice play lorenzo kane got a great jump
gliding through
left center to make that play for out
number one
punches a single right
[Applause]
simmons bounces a base head to right
custodial will be condemned content with
second base
so five hits for the twins
in the first
nine played appearances bases full of
twins already in front two to nothing
try it again
kenya wants it inside lauer
in there a cold strike three a cutter
polanco got caught guessing yes he did
he had a good pitch to head right down
the middle
got away with that that's the third
strikeout for lauer
two and two
and he got him big curveball and a
strikeout
you can hear the brewers fans
at target field tonight back-to-back
case
oh a shot off the glove and then to
center field
oh yeah it's hit that like a rocket
there's a fastball out away from him
i mean that's a knuckle ball right there
folks i mean that's what you call good
solid contact squaring it up
that ball didn't have much rotation on
it did it
and rowdy
sneaks one through base head
had a little bit of a shift on that
space was open for him and teles with a
two strike
two out base head
that hit him
manny pina hit by a pitch
that's going to load the bases here in
the fourth
[Applause]
simmons is right there and he'll walk
through the bag pretty well hit ball off
the slope of the mound right to the
shortstop sixth inning we'll begin with
christian yelich at the plate chopped to
first sono tough hop albers is there and
he got there
just before yelich
albers does a good job getting over
there we've talked about left easy you
see albers break right away
getting over there
[Applause]
that's miggy right there he goes down
and gets down on that ball
and so albert gets there
bronco ball deli out slicing and dyson
through the brewers offense tonight he
leaves after five and a third scoreless
innings she's gonna get a nice ovation
from the crowd
and now kepler hit the ball hard twice
tonight
good night at the plate for kepler he
put the barrel into the ball three times
and has two hits
and a good at bat there he's at first
with one down for ostadia
snagging a base there
toward the hole nice knock down
and simmons will reach on an infield hit
but a great play by ureas keeping that
ball in the infield kepler held at third
urais does a nice job i think he's saved
a run right there that ball is going to
die in the outfield grass i think kepler
goes and
scores pretty easily so nice play by
urias
oh here's the moment we've been waiting
for buxton in with runners on the
corners and two down
mena sets up inside he deals a fastball
called strike three
perfectly spotted fastball by
jake cousins and buxton left standing
there with two on
and here is colton wong
and wong a base head to right man this
guy's something
and what's new another base hit against
a lefty that's two tonight
[Applause]
he's got yellow joe too
got him struck him out with a slider
the two big outs right there long
singles to start the inning
coulomb get to rius and yelich
perfect pitch with two strikes slider
off the edge
too close for yellows to take
first slider of the at-bat was a little
bit off but got the call kind of a
toss-up tonight
got him with a slow breaking ball
duffy gets garcia and it's still two to
nothing
[Applause]
garcia got himself tossed and jackie
bradley jr finds himself on right field
now
got him looking over the inside edge
[Music]
and kane picks up the argument
that garcia had to close out the eighth
inning
two and two
got him
a swing and a miss two down
a high fly to center field
buxton has it measured
and the twins win the opener two to
nothing
well a really well pitched ball game
started with andrew albers
a shout out for the twins josh donaldson
homer in the first inning stands
a two-nothing twins win